monica good morning how are we doing i'm
feeling okay how are you
just rocking and rolling figuring it out
awesome so what's up how can i help so
as a conservative christian
how do i teach my kids accurate
information on lgbtq plus issues while
maintaining biblical teachings on the
subject
well that's a great question um so dig
into that a little bit
tell me what's behind that um just my
kid
one of my kids is getting older and how
old um
okay and it's something that's going to
start coming up more and more as she
gets older i want her to have
good information so she can know you
know what other people might be going
through if it comes up for her what she
might be going through
and you know just so that we can raise
them with a christ-like compassion to
where
they can love um have the love of god
and all mankind
hmm number one i love your heart here
man that's
it's so good here there feels like
there's another side to this so
are you are you afraid that teaching
them hospitality
is going to set them up in this like
what what's the other the or what part
of this
the or what part of it is probably um
you know okay this sounds terrible but
you know what if they come out what kind
of mom am i going to be
am i going to mourn that and not support
them you know
obviously they're young i don't know
they don't know but if it does come up
when they're older
um you know how do we navigate that
that comes up so is this more about
you wanting to teach them is this more
about you
prepping for a conversation
that almost pre-worrying about a
situation that may or may not come down
the road someday
yeah and then my own i'm trying to
navigate through my own discomfort
with the issue as well well number one i
appreciate you being honest and
being brave um early on in the show we
received a number of phone calls
and i i finally just asked on this topic
and when i was still practicing so those
shows didn't air just because i was
terrible to know what i was doing um but
one time i just
asked hey why are you calling me like
why don't you ask your friends
and the response was haunting the
response was
deloney i got nobody to ask and
i i've just been so fortunate to have
such a great community over the years
and so i
i'm so grateful that you reached out i
know so many folks are working through
this and thinking through these
these things and wanting to be graceful
and
loving so um
to answer your first question you're
gonna love your kid
the fact that you're calling lets me
know that you're gonna
you're gonna love your kid every mom
every dad on planet earth has this
imaginary picture for their child of
what that's going to look like
and 99.9 of them are wrong right
they're not going to look that way in it
and it's
not just on this topic in fact it's
rarely on this topic it's about i wanted
him to be a baseball player or a lawyer
or a doctor
or i thought they were going to marry
somebody with dark hair or blonde hair
whatever the thing is
and so if this comes up hey you're going
to love your kid
b you're gonna mourn the picture that
you had in your head it just plopped in
there whether society put it in there
you put it in there your parents put it
whatever it came from
right my wife talks about this future
thanksgiving table someday
and and when our kids come home from
college and
yada and i just smile because it's not
gonna happen but it's so fun to think
about right
so um both of those things can be true
so here's here's my thoughts and i'm
gonna like be as honest as i can i've
got
um a lot of
lgbtq friends and i've got a lot of
community members i mean that's that's
been my world is hospitality
over the last 10 15 20 years so
your impulse is first is right it's
hospitality first
like just understand how hard it is for
folks whatever they're walking through
each day
it's just hard right the second thing is
you can't
undermine christian teaching you can
undermine your faith's witness
and what i mean by that is as a
christian person
and i'm one too so i'll speak to the
preacher the choir here
we have to hold in our hands this idea
that we are looking for truth and trying
to
feel and read and be taught truth and at
the same time recognize that throughout
history we've been wrong a lot
and we've been right a lot we do a lot
of good in the world
christian communities a lot a lot of
good
and we've been really really wrong
and so what i have shifted over the last
decade is less of a focus on
i'm being right on all these topics and
issues and
shifted way more towards everybody's
welcome at delony's house
everybody's welcome at my table and we
will navigate relationships together
we will navigate topics together um but
every one of those quote unquote what's
the right answer will always be done in
relationships right
um and then just for whatever it's worth
for you there are so
many there's such a diverse array of
faith-based voices out there now
um when you said conservative christian
that means 50 different things to 50
different people
i'm interested in your definition what
does that mean to you
um i think it means more i guess
traditional christian
okay um so what so i'll even push
like so what does that even mean you've
got john wesley and john calvin and
martin luther and the catholic community
i mean that means so many things
um what is what is that what does that
mean
so i guess when i say conservative
christian to this topic
i mean um you know
sorry this is a hard topic because you
know i feel like the worst person ever
having my viewpoints being kind of
behind
um hold on for a second hold on a second
you're not the worst person here's why
you're asking questions you are asking
questions and you are wrestling with
hard things
right so you're not the worst person
right if you were
yelling on the side of the street
throwing rocks at people then i would
lump you into that's not cool category
but the fact that you're asking
questions
uh makes you a truth seeker and the fact
that you're asking relationships to
people
and not to alexa tells me you want
relationships and those that's i mean
that's the two greatest things
a person can be doing right now so good
for you okay
um so go ahead
um so you know traditionally marriage
um ideally is between a man and woman i
mean
um ideally like i if i have friends who
are in that community and get married
you know i'll go to their wedding great
for them this is
you know totally happy for them um
you know but just again marriage between
men and women is ideal
um i think that's what i mean
by conservative christian so just the
picture of marriage there
yeah okay and let's like in the
relationship stuff and everything
up and down and um middle schoolers
being asked to declare
and what what's the right this and
what's right that what i want to
always push you back towards which is
this is where you're at by the way
is relationship and hospitality right
and
focusing less on having all the right
answers
and having all of the deepest
relationships possible
here's the the challenging thing um
we have we have decided some things in
our faith communities over the years
over all those different branches of
of christianity for what that means and
we have focused on some things
not focused on other things chosen some
things not just
every group has different thoughts and
and
um threads that run through it sexual
stewardship is
is a big one giving is a big one
hospitality is a big one
loving your neighbor as yourself is a
big one right and so
for you and your family for you and your
faith community
um defaulting to relationship and
hospitality don't be scared of yourself
and what might happen with your kid
someday
i can tell you right now you're gonna
love your child y'all may have hard
conversations
and uh spoiler alert even if your kid
ends up not being a member of the lgbt
community
you're still gonna have a ton of hard
conversations together right
yeah what is it about yourself that you
don't trust
about compassion about care because you
sound like a loving person
you sound almost like you're ashamed of
asking hard questions
you know it probably goes back to the
way i was raised i was raised by
um unfortunately people who weren't as
loving
and so i guess it's you know kind of
ingrained in me to
be judgmental and less loving and
i don't want to be that person you know
that's not in me who i am
but it's kind of part of me at the same
time because it's what i grew up with
but here's what's making me smile right
now and you can't see it but i'm smiling
real big because
um chances are the folks who raised you
did the best they could with the tools
ahead in their toolkit right
and they did the best they could with
what they knew with the air they were
breathing in the water they were
drinking
and what you're doing is like that old
maya angelou quote you do the best that
you can and then when you know more
you do better and that's what you're
trying to do right you're trying to be
less dogmatic and more in love with
people it doesn't mean that we throw all
the baby out the bathwater there is some
ways of living that we got to hang on to
right there is some discipline and
accountability
and quote unquote right ways of living
there are
and i'll go to task with anybody who
says no dude it's just whatever you feel
bro it's all cool it's not all cool it's
a mess
right but all of that starts in
relationship
and i don't know what to tell you other
than i think you are
absolutely on the right track and here's
the thing the right track doesn't mean
that you and i
end up believing the same things on
everything it does mean that we end up
with
an understanding we're going to treat
people with respect and dignity wherever
they happen to fall
does that make sense yeah that makes
sense
so i don't know that i'm answering your
question as much as affirming you
as somebody who is trying to navigate a
messy messy situation in a messy messy
world and trying to reckon with her past
and thoughts you may have had and jokes
you may have told and
and people you may have told off and
arguments you may have thought you have
won
with this new person who's looking at
their 10 year old thinking you are
inheriting a totally different world
than i come from and i don't know any
way forward other than to lead on love
and relationship
yes with discipline yes with it's
following
finding truth in rightness as best as we
possibly can
but man it is it is love and
relationship first and then we figure
out the rest as we go
i i think you're i think your kids are
lucky to have you as their mom
of the greatest gifts listen one of the
greatest gifts monica my mom
and dad have given me is the fact that
they were both
super conservative christians over time
i would still consider them super
conservative christians
and i can't tell you the number of times
they've told me i changed my mind
i was wrong on this and i need to think
about it this way now
and that is a that over the the this
particular issue
that's the greatest gift that i look at
them and they're in their 70s now
and they hold really firm to some some
truths and they have said i changed my
mind on this one or i'm still wrestling
with this one
i changed my mind i changed it back and
i'm thinking about changing it again all
of it has been this loop
but for me like i said less than this is
the way
it has been here's how we're going to
approach it
we're going to try to figure out we're
going to always be trying to read
something that makes us uncomfortable
we're going to always be trying to have
hard conversations we're going to
always be meeting with the least of
these and the marginalized and those who
are hurting in our communities whoever
and wherever they end up being and then
we're going to try to wrap our heads
around what that means in light of
this ancient text that we hang on to
and we're going to be challenged and
frustrated and ask hard questions
and we're going to come back to love and
we're going to get angry and we're going
to have to look at our neighbor and say
hey i totally disagree with you
i actually at the end of the day have
worked hard on this and i think this is
this is a universal truth here but come
over and
have a glass of wine and we're gonna
figure it out you're always welcome at
my house
and man i think your kids are lucky to
have you monica